une question qu'on se pose et vous allez
poser c'est est-ce que l'élection de
miss univers d'iris milton r est truqué
et l'attention parce que ça ne concerne
donc miss france 2016 mais également
miss univers on va être précis en fait
aux états unis au cours du concours de
miss univers est diffusée pour et
produit par la chaîne fox qui appartient
harper murdoch ce même rupert murdoch
s'est allié en 2014 avec la société
endemol pour créer un géant la
production tv et deux ans plus tard une
artiste mais tonnerre est élue miss
univers
alors on se pose la question est-ce qu
endemol qui produit le concours miss
france at il été favorisée pour le
concours miss univers
vous avez posé la question est légitime
c'est vrai que pendant 40 ans on est
allé au concours miss univers en est
revenue à chaque fois bredouille avec
pourtant des miss france qui était
vraiment très ravissante et puis
effectivement la miss univers c'est
comme passer comme miss france mais
c'est vers novi n'existe que par sa
retransmission télévisée si si demain
tf1 lâche puisse france à s'écroule
immédiatement c'est pareil pour miss
univers est actuellement c'est fox tv
qui retransmet ce concours est faux que
steevy appartiendra père murdoch et
rupert murdoch a acheté endemol et donc
à acheter miss france les serrures
autour des d'ailleurs un essai il s'est
retourné il semblerait que non mais vous
êtes en train de lire qui aurait eu de
la triche madrid je peux poser une
question avec monsieur de son père
représente qui aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est là et vous jouez aux chiens
l'honneur d'un homme nu chez nous et au
delà il est parfaitement honorable il
vient avec des informations et vous
dites oui vous avez voulu vendre votre
truc votre truc
mais qui êtes vous à la fin pernikoff
jeu vers le fait votre liberté
quel droit monsieur woerth a laissé le
final avait dit suffisamment de
conneries pour la soirée
il a vendu la société ya deux saisons il
a un devoir de réserve et non mais il va
bien il vient avec des informations il
en a plein il a tous les dossiers
je les ai vus pas puisqu'il dit il
paraîtrait il paraîtrait moi j'ai
réécouté des choses pour bien faire mon
job aujourd'hui il a déclaré que la
vente à lui a rapporté 6 millions
d'euros hamon a pu voir un plus un clou
et demi d'euros est resté chez lui
cinq cent mille chez madame de fontenay
enfin tout a été déclaré et un rendu en
arrière et on remet tout en cause
gilles et en plus on est presque en
train de salir un événement annuel 1
ça vous salue c'est un homme pas
d'accord il est parfaitement de sa maman
tu perds le passage de 30 à 12 il a tous
les dossiers une opacité maintenant que
c'est endemol du passage de 30 à 12 sur
la facturation vous avez vu le bénéfice
qui fut en europe ayant toilettes j'ai
vu j'y vois pas d'une amie lyon 6 à
rester j'ai vu les chiffres j'ai fait
ces dossiers d'arrêter pernikoff enfin
la suite mais ce qui me dit girard il me
dit tu peux pas laisser dire autant de
conneries
voilà tout dit mais on a dit beaucoup
aussi dit beaucoup aussi quand ils
venaient ici sous licence et donc je re
de pouvoir enfin donner mon point de vue
quand même le souci c'est qu'il n'a pas
il a bien parlé elle suit le pardon il a
bien parlé sur les chaînes et là les
chaînes à endemol et tout ça ça ça me
plaît comme argument pour la pour la
tricherie
mais après moi je rejoins nicolas si on
t'a donné séparément si on vous a donné
l'argent
vous avez pris l'argent après vous
voulez pas qu'on vous fasse et la
journée taisez vous demandez dans un
état des mois 6 millions ou verrai plus
jamais
[Applaudissements]